I landed a
$30,000 copyrighting gig just 6 months
after I started copyrighting and in
today's video I'm going to give you the
exact step-by-step framework that I use
to get really ridiculously good at
copyrighting super fast let's Dive Right
In actually before we dive into the
video I have a gift for you assuming
that you are a copywriter I want to give
you copyrighting Catalyst 63 cash cow
copyrighting tips that can help you go
from Zero to Hero
very quickly okay each tip takes 90
seconds or less to read and I promise
you they're going to give you some
insane copyrighting insights all you got
to do is hit the link in the description
below put in your email tell me where to
send it and I will get it to your inbox
immediately for you to start studying
all right now let's dive into the video
I know when I was starting my
copyrighting journey I was filled with
just like random generic advice on like
Twitter and Reddit and Facebook that was
like study the the fundamentals a master
persuasion and all these random things
that they put in Threads and then you're
like well how do I do that what do I
read where do am I supposed to read am I
supposed to write like should I write a
daily email should I write ads should I
like I don't know what to do like it all
just seems very overwhelming and so
you're probably feeling overwhelmed the
same way that I was then so I want to
simplify I built this exact system for
myself I've not seen anybody build a
system like this or use any kind of
learning tactics like this maybe it
exists out there but I built this for me
because I wanted to get really really
good fast so I hope that this simple
system works for you okay so for this
system I break out your learning into
two different buckets okay there's
Active Learning and there's passive
learning let's talk about what each of
those are and how they actually merge
together okay so first let's talk about
passive learning passive learning is
basically like information intake of
some level this is like reading books
watching videos listening to podcasts
going through a course these are things
that a lot of people online gurus will
tell you this is a waste of time but
they also sell all these products so I
don't understand but yeah they'll tell
you like reading is a waste of time just
get to work and blah blah blah these
guys are idiots let me tell you why
passive learning is not a waste of time
and why we will combine it in today's
get really good system that I'm teaching
you okay so it's not a waste of time
because there are guys like Gary Bena
and John Carlton and Gary Halpert and
Ben settle and Daniel thrussell and all
these guys who have worked years to
master copyrighting and they've packaged
their insights and their wisdom what
goes well what doesn't go well they've
they've packaged these insights into
some sort of book course video whatever
for you to get way ahead way faster okay
so instead of you bumbling around your
copyrighting journey just like it's like
oh you know what it doesn't work when I
you know do a 7-Day deadline instead of
a 3-day deadline well yeah somebody
already figured that out and wrote it in
a book so there's lots of insights into
the copyrighting world that you can
actually glean from passive learning
books courses videos podcast things like
that which right ding ding ding of
course it still works so we're
definitely going to include passive
learning as part of our get really good
really fast system the other half of
this is active learning and there's only
really two good forms of active learning
especially for copyrighting and that is
writing copy and copy chiefing or
editing right there's only two forms to
get really really good so you're either
going to be writing some sort of copy or
you're going to be editing some sort of
copy and I would dare say that the eding
part is actually way more robust for
learning than the writing part but both
are very enjoyable and we need both in
our framework now to be clear Active
Learning will get you really good a lot
faster than passive learning will okay
so if you do a lot of passive learning
but you're not applying it actively it's
not going to work so I built a system
that actually Loops big looping routine
that goes from passive to active from
passive to active and it just goes back
and forth and back and forth so here's
exactly what you need to do to combine
these systems to get really good what I
like to do is I like to take one form of
passive learning and combine it with one
form of active learning and repeat that
cycle over and over okay so for example
out of the passive learning I like to
learn by reading okay some of you guys
like to learn by watching videos like
this or taking a course or whatever like
I like to learn by reading okay so I
want to read a book let's say I go get a
book well here let me show
you yeah let's say we go get a book like
cashvertising okay and for my mass of
learning I'm going to read for you know
whatever 10 15 minutes which is fine
right so I get in cashvertising and
let's say I open up and I get to this
point in cash vertising where it says
that short headlines are stronger than
long headlines or they're actually more
well read right so more people will read
a short headline than a long headline
okay so let's say I'm reading I learned
that from cash vertising that's passive
learning I just learned a new concept
now I'm going to take that and attach it
to to my preferred way of active
learning okay so for your Active
Learning and copyrighting you just
attach it to the style of copywriting
you prefer the most whether you're
writing sales letters emails which is my
preferred method of copywriting I'm an
email copywriter or meta ads Google
headlines vsls whatever your form method
for the sake of this demonstration I'm
going to say emails okay so emails so I
like reading which is my passive
learning and I like writing emails which
is my active learning so I'm going to
create a loop that's constantly learning
some New Concept through Reading and
then applying it by writing an email
super simple that's it that's the whole
system okay so once a day I will read
for about 30 minutes and I will write an
email for about 30 minutes so that's a
60c loop and basically what I'm trying
to do is I'm trying to take one concept
that I learned from Reading like that's
just one example right okay so I read
cash r I learned that short headlines
might get read more than long headlines
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
write an email with a short subject line
maybe three words or two words that's me
testing something new that I learned
okay so that's passive learning to
Active Learning the next thing here now
I might put this up let's go get another
book okay let's say I'm reading very
good copy okay I've got this book and
it's 400 Pages you're going to learn a t
but let's say I flip through here and I
now get to the message of okay here's a
here's a great lesson right here it's
show don't tell okay don't tell somebody
a story show them you are in the story
by adding dialogue to your copy so
instead of saying I went to the
supermarket maybe start with
a I ended up in the supermarket and blah
blah blah and you start talking back and
forth hey where are your cucumbers at
you know whatever and you're teaching
dialogue okay well now I just learned
that by reading it I read it it's a
concept I underlined it I highlighted it
okay now I'm going to bookmark my book
put it down and I'm going to go write an
email and I say okay how can I include
this in an email so that's the entire
Loop and you just do it over and over
and over again one book that you're
learning from or one course might teach
you 50 Concepts so now you have 50 days
worth of practice and if you do this
Loop once a day an hour a day every day
for 30 days 60 days imagine if you did
it for 6 months in fact that's exactly
what I did I did this for 6 months and
after 6 months I was good enough to get
that $330,000 copyrighting gig right it
was a flat fee plus rev share because I
performed for them and I ended up
getting a commission on doing so well
and that's because I had been practicing
these copyrighting concepts for 6 months
so it's not complicated it just takes a
lot of work right an hour a day of work
which honestly isn't that much work
especially for such a fruitful and
rewarding career in copyrighting now I
know some of you are already thinking
well Allan I don't have a daily email
list like you or I don't have clients to
write copy for that's okay do it for
yourself this is not a time for you to
earn it's a time for you to learn so
even if you don't have a daily email
list first off it's free you can
literally just go open a daily email
list text 50 friends and family put it
on Twitter get a few people on there
right whatever it is or write a blog
doesn't M like write a daily blog that
is copyrighting posted it on the
internet even if nobody's reading or
honestly just create a running Google
doc create a new tab for every day and
just write an email to yourself or for a
fake product or for a product that you
enjoy it doesn't matter you are learning
at this point so you need to stop the
excuses and just get to work okay learn
a concept practice it learn a concept
practice it that's it that's the whole
formula okay you have a laptop you have
Google Docs it's absolutely free your
Apple notes doesn't matter get to work
today that is my whole concept some
people watch this video and be like oh
it's too simple but I guarantee if you
do the work it's abs absolutely going to
be very fruitful for you so I hope that
you enjoyed this video let me give you
some great recommendations before you go
though if you like me and you like
reading I'm back uh a couple books that
honestly will just like keep you busy
for like 3 years um I mentioned it
before very good copy great book super
easy to read it looks big but honestly
the concepts are really good and it
literally has 207 micro lessons on
thinking and writing like a copyright so
literally that's 207 days of something
you can practice cashvertising has like
a billion in there literally what is it
100 Secrets there's like way more than
100 by the way so that's there's there's
a whole Year's worth of tips right in
there and then another one that I really
like is the ad week copywriting handbook
so you can take any of these again
literally take that open up a Google doc
take one concept that you learn apply it
you're making money today any who I hope
that was helpful L copy go here and if
you are not on my email list go to Allen
dro.com where you can read my daily
emails you can see me put this stuff in
action live you can read my Sensational
storytelling emails that make it really
addictive for people to enjoy the
copyrighting space I'm glad to be in
there I hope you're reading them and if
you are not what is wrong with you why
are you here why are you watching my
videos but not reading my work I don't
understand I'm kidding just come and if
you don't enjoy it you can unsubscribe
anytime so I appreciate you thank thank
you so much and I will chat with you
soon
[Music]